President Trump says he is declaring a
national emergency to build a border
wall because of what he calls an
invasion from the south the president
made that declaration official this
morning president conceding he will be
sued but is predicting success
eventually chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has the story
tonight from the North Lawn good evening
John Breck good evening to you White
House officials tell Fox News that
attorney spent weeks going through all
of the ins and outs of an emergency
declaration to make sure that the
president would be on solid ground today
still he stirred up a hornet's nest with
a stroke of his executive pen President
Trump today invited what may be the
biggest challenge to his executive power
yet we're talking about an invasion of
our country with drugs with human
traffickers with all types of criminals
and gangs in total president Trump is
looking at eight billion dollars to
build his border wall 1.3 7 billion from
the DHS appropriation 601 million from
the Treasury Department's forfeiture
fund two and a half billion from the
Pentagon's drug interdiction program
including 2.2 billion that will be
reprogrammed from other areas of the
Pentagon and three point six billion
dollars from the military construction
budget Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer and Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi ripped the president for raiding
the Pentagon budget to build a wall in a
joint statement saying the president's
unlawful declaration over a crisis that
does not exist does great violence to
our Constitution and makes America less
safe stealing from urgently needed
defense funds for the security of our
military and our nation the president
today insisted moving the money would
not hurt the military we had certain
funds that are being used at the
discretion of generals at the discretion
of the military some of them haven't
been allocated yet and some of the
generals think that this is more
important in making his case President
Trump today pointed to dozens of
emergency declarations that never drew
the type of fire he's receiving but
those declarations weren't used as a way
to go around Congress on Appropriations
the president also gave his critics more
ammunition today when he
seemed to indicate the emergency
declaration wasn't necessary I didn't
need to do this but I'd rather do it
much faster and I don't have to do it
for the election I've already done a lot
of wall socialist firebrand
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
said she'd introduced legislation to
block the president tweeting Joaquin
Castro Texas and I aren't going to let
the president declare a fake national
emergency without a fight a
congressional fight may be the least of
the president's worries White House
officials even the president openly
acknowledged their attempt to reprogram
military money will lend them in court
they will sue us in the Ninth Circuit
even though it shouldn't be there and we
will possibly get a bad ruling and then
we'll get another bed ruling and then
we'll end up in the Supreme Court and
hopefully we'll get a fair shake and
we'll win in the Supreme Court the words
had barely escaped escape the
president's lips when the ACLU announced
ACLU rather announced that it would sue
the President and Democrats on the house
homeland rather Democrats in the House
Judiciary Committee I'm sorry today sent
a letter to the White House saying that
they wanted to investigate the
president's emergency declaration and
asked the White House to make officials
from both here and the Department of
Justice available for the hearings Brett
more on this with the panel John Roberts
Laughlin no it's lon John thanks